nothing unites ghanaians like football
and when the national team plays nearly
everything comes to a standstill
if it's a win the country erupts in
Celebration
but when they lose controversially like
the 2010 World Cup quart final match
against Uruguay The Grudge stays
Samuel and coomb who represented Ghana
in two World Cups played in that match
he says when Uruguay's Luis Suarez
deliberately use his hand to prevent a
gyne goal there was anger and disbelief
to be honest everybody want to beat him
to be honest because you know this is
something that we plan for it we've been
training for so long and when you talk
about World Cup World Cup is about four
years four years so you going there you
never know maybe in the next four years
you cannot go
but he said sportsmanship was what held
them back
12 years after Louis Suarez is in famous
handball that denied Ghana the winner in
the quarterfinals many Guardians are
still bitter about their loss they see
this year's tournament has a chance to
get even
the call for revenge is loud but sport
commentators are urging caution
sometimes I say to my friends you need
seven or eight games to win the World
Cup maximum and that's for me should be
the target not to say that I want to go
to the quarterfinals or semi-finals but
to say that I'm going to win all my
matches and that you see me through to a
particular stage
Ghana are grouped with Uruguay in Qatar
and Suarez who was responsible for
Ghana's loss that day in 2010 it's also
set to play for the country
Accra